[Música]
[Aplausos]
en los años 60 la carrera espacial está
en su apogeo Europa observa Cómo
estadounidenses y soviéticos acumulan
proezas aclaman a sus héroes y compiten
por llegar a la luna
[Aplausos]
en esa época estábamos realmente en
pañales en comparación con los
estadounidenses y la idea sólo era tener
un programa de acceso independiente al
espacio tras varios fracasos Europa se
reorganiza colectivamente y lanza el
programa arian en 1973
Si se quiere tener un rol en el espacio
lo primero que hay que tener es acceso a
esto
el acceso al espacio es una cuestión de
soberanía es fundamental y estratégico
un recorrido por medio siglo de
exploración espacial Europea y los retos
a los que se enfrenta arian 6
a partir de los años 50 Francia potencia
nuclear desarrolla sus propios
lanzadores primero veronic y después de
amor se convierte así en el tercer país
en lanzar su propio satélite asterix
Francia fue el motor de arian y arian y
la disuasión nuclear estaban
relacionados cuando un país empieza a
fabricar cohetes a menudo es porque
quiere fabricar misiles que es más o
menos lo mismo Francia es sin duda el
motor de arena
a principios de los años 70 los europeos
no disponen de un lanzador potente
tienen que poner sus mayores satélites
en órbita desde Estados Unidos
desarrollar arian era ante todo una
necesidad estratégica
los antecedentes de esta historia son el
desarrollo de un satélite Franco alemán
llamado symphony y las condiciones que
impusieron los estadounidenses para
ponerlo en órbita
En otras palabras Estados Unidos dijo sí
también lanzar todo lo que quieran desde
Estados Unidos somos aliados pero no
piensen en hacer negocios con esos
satélites Fue entonces que los europeos
entendieron que la autonomía tenía un
precio tener acceso al espacio sin
depender de los estadounidenses ni de
otras potencias Crea una necesidad debía
ponerse en marcha un gran programa
espacial
Francia a través de su agencia espacial
Ness ASUME el mando del proyecto arian
financiando el 60% de este kuruú en la
guayana francesa se convierte en la base
de lanzamiento europea
Por qué la agencia espacial francesa
porque ya habíamos trabajado en veroniki
Damián
que fueron un éxito así que ya teníamos
una experiencia comprobada reconocida en
toda Europa
Francia era de lejos el país más
avanzado en el sector espacial por eso
se le pidió alquimines la agencia
espacial francesa que encabezara que
dirigiera este programa
La elección misma del nombre arian es
muy simbólica y tiene raíces europeas
arian es una referencia a la mitología
griega ella le dio a teseo un hilo para
ayudarlo a salir del Laberinto que se
había construido para encerrar al
minotauro harían actualmente es Quien
salvó Europa de las repetidas quiebras y
fracasos en materia de exploración
espacial
Esta es la versión mitológica la
realidad es probablemente menos
romántica
fue un ministro llamado quien en un
consejo celebrado en Bruselas sugirió el
nombre de arian porque el ministro tenía
varios hijos pero no tenía ninguna hija
dijo que si tuviera una hija le pondrían
Entonces sugirió ese nombre y esa es la
razón por la cual el programa fue
nombrado así
[Música]
los brazos criogénicos se desplegaron
correctamente kuru 18 horas 14 minutos
38 segundos habían despega sobre el
cielo del centro espacial de guayana
propulsado por las 250 toneladas de los
cuatro motores de su primera etapa un
ascenso vertical perfecto que podemos
ver gracias a 12 cámaras de televisión
esta primera etapa estará encendida
durante 145 segundos es decir durante
casi dos minutos y medio durante estos
dos minutos y medio de ascenso harían
usará una tonelada de combustible por
segundo
habíamos trabajado como locos durante
varias semanas sobre todo durante la
última semana y este éxito inesperado
fue la clave para el resto ya que se
creía poco en el proyecto de hecho
Adrián fue el primer lanzador del mundo
con el que se probaron las tres etapas
al mismo tiempo y en tener éxito en el
primer intento
como todos los cohetes Ariana se
enfrenta fracasos
arian está despegando la sigue el
telescopio de las islas de la salvación
habrían explotó arian acaba de explotar
es terrible es terrible marianne acaba
de todo se acabó es terrible
los accidentes no impiden que el
proyecto evolucione harían uno le sucede
en el 2 3 4 y el mítico harían 5 cada
versión crece en capacidad fiabilidad y
potencia a finales de los años 80 el
cohete se convierte en el principal
lanzador de satélites comerciales del
mundo
eran los días de Gloria harían cinco
dominó el mercado durante 20 años es de
realmente la punta de lanza de la
exploración espacial estar a la
vanguardia no solo fue gracias al
trabajo duro también fue gracias a la
suerte
suerte o un trágico accidente en 1986 su
competencia el transbordador espacial
estadounidense deja de realizar
lanzamientos comerciales son las 11
horas 38 minutos en Cabo Cañaveral y el
transbordador sale por fin de la
plataforma de lanzamiento su trayectoria
es casi recta y todo parece ir bien en
todo caso nada hace pensar que se
producirá una catástrofe un minuto y 45
segundos después de su lanzamiento el
transbordador no era más que una bola de
fuego con una Estela de llamas y
combustible en nuestros pensamientos
están los siete astronautas atrapados en
las llamas
y en 1986 ocurre el accidente del
Challenger lo que llevó al presidente
Reagan a prohibir el uso comercial del
transbordador por lo tanto no se
lanzarían más satélites desde el
transbordador Entonces todos los
clientes que deseaban lanzar satélites
comerciales recurren a arianne
el éxito de arian se debe tanto a su
calidad como a las dificultades que
tuvieron los estadounidenses con este
cohete el programa estadounidense
resultó ser más caro más complicado y
más peligroso de lo previsto el fracaso
era muy dramático significó perder vidas
humanas y no solo un gran montón de
chatarra por cara que está afuera
arian No es solo un éxito tecnológico y
comercial es también una proeza política
un símbolo de la unidad europea
los objetos
Europa puede ser un impulso pero también
un freno porque el espacio es un negocio
tan caro que nadie puede permitírselo
por sí solo
el objetivo es sacar lo mejor de cada
uno y no olvidemos que arian también ha
sido un vector en el desarrollo de las
capacidades industriales europeas
una regla sencilla cada país que
financia el programa recibe contratos
equivalentes a su inversión
todos ponen un poco en la olla y Todos
quieren tener prosperidad en su país Así
que quieren poseer un pedazo del cohete
en Europa existe el principio del
retorno geográfico hacemos cohetes
bastante complicados en los que deben
participar todos los países hablando de
cohetes complicados este es Ariana 6 un
cohete de 3000 millones de euros
financiado por 13 países europeos y que
debía estar listo hace tres años el
problema actual de arian es que se hace
esperar
ahí radica el error casi filosófico el
error estratégico de Europa es que en
vez de hacer algo más eficaz lo que
quieren hacer es más sofisticado así que
en vez de hacer algo sencillo con
tecnologías que conocen y que controlan
para reducir gastos y lanzarlo
rápidamente los europeos se dedicaron a
desarrollar tecnologías que eran
completamente nuevas y en la industria
del espacio lo mejor es trabajando con
las tecnologías que funcionan
sin embargo harían 6 es un 40% menos
costoso y es revolucionario su última
etapa puede volver a encenderse para
lanzar varios satélites a órbitas
diferentes
pero desde que su construcción empezó en
2014 todo ha cambiado hay un nuevo
competidor que está revolucionando el
acceso al espacio encendido y despegue
del falcon 9 hacia la estación espacial
internacional en el primer vuelo
comercial desde el centro espacial
Kennedy y su legendaria plataforma de
lanzamiento 39a
Mientras tanto spacex ha avanzado a una
rapidez vertiginosa que ninguno de los
especialistas del programa arian había
previsto
un lanzador reutilizable confiable y
menos costoso capaz de realizar más de
60 vuelos al año la empresa Privada de
elon musk ha triunfado donde los
transbordadores espaciales habían
fracasado
lo que ocurre hoy es lo que teníamos que
ocurriera hace 45 años pero no hay
motivos para alarmarse harían ya
superado obstáculos similares
harían 6 con años de retraso es
demasiado grande no es reutilizable y es
objeto de críticas sin embargo tiene
pedidos para los próximos tres años 28
lanzamientos previstos 18 de ellos para
Jeff bezos y su constelación de
satélites un contrato histórico por más
de mil millones de euros
estos pequeños satélites serán lanzados
en órbita baja a una altitud de 600 km
el objetivo es ofrecer internet de alta
velocidad a todo el planeta de aquí a
2030 la batalla de las constelaciones
hasta ahora empieza
los clientes de arian ya no quieren
lanzar un gran satélite de
telecomunicaciones de cinco o seis
toneladas hoy quieren desplegar
constelaciones o sea los satélites son
cada vez más pequeños pero hay que
desplegar muchos de ellos a diferentes
órbitas
nos permitirá ofrecer soluciones para
este cambio del mercado de los satélites
geoestacionarios a las constelaciones
una adaptación necesaria tras haber sido
el monopolio de las agencias
gubernamentales el acceso al espacio se
está trasladando ahora al sector privado
Pero sigue siendo una cuestión vital
para las grandes potencias
los estadounidenses lanzan sus satélites
con lanzadores estadounidenses los
chinos con lanzadores chinos entonces
una parte darían seis tiene que ver con
la soberanía su misión es poderle
garantizar a Europa pase lo que pase Y
sean cuales sean sus acuerdos o
desacuerdos con sus socios y vecinos la
posibilidad de enviar sus satélites al
espacio
50 años después del inicio del programa
la cuestión de la soberanía vuelve a
plantearse con el retiro de harían 5
Europa debe lanzar temporalmente sus
satélites desde Estados Unidos se espera
que harían 6 esté finalmente listo a
finales de año